ان كنتم تظنون ان هذا الصيف حار فانتظر
الصيف المقبل قد تشهدون الحراره الاعلى
عبر التاريخ هذا ما اكده علماء امريكيون
وذلك بفعل ظاهره النينو التي بدات تتشكل
فعليا فوق المحيط الهادئ
يمكن ان تؤدي ظاهره المينيو الى تسجيل عام
2024 في دفاتر الارقام القياسيه ولكن يبقى
كل شيء مرتبطا بحركه الغلاف الجوي غير
المنتظمه وتغيرات الطقس التي تلعب دورا
ايضا في ذلك ولكن معظم السنوات الاكثر حرا
المسجله في الماضي حدثت بسبب تاثير ظاهره
النينيو التي سوف تعطي دفعه اضافيه لدرجات
الحراره العالميه اضافه للاحتباس الحراري
الذي تسبب فيه الانسان تحدث ظاهره
نينو نتيجه التباين في درجات حراره مياه
سطح المحيط الهادئ تندفع كميات كبيره من
المياه الى الغلاف الجوي فتغرق اجزاء من
امريكا الوسطى والجنوبيه بالفيضانات ويضرب
الجفاف استراليا وشرق اسيا حيث تشتعل
حرائق الغابات وتموت المزروعات عطشا ما قد
يتسبب بخسائر اقتصاديه قدرها ثلاثه
تريليونات دولار وفقا مجله
النانو ستفاقم ازمه الاحترار العالمي
لتتجاوز الكره الارضيه عتبه زياده الحرجه
في درجات الحراره خلال العام القادم وهي
درجه ونصف درجه مئويه وفق اتفاقيه باريس
للمناخ الخبر صار ان لظاهره
نينوى اختان اسمها لانينا عاده ما تحل
بعدها لتبرد الارض وتعد الطبيعه الى حالها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات